the Joe Rogan experience that's just as
that's [ __ ] dangerous man that's with
because if you lose to a wrestler or you
lose to a jiu-jitsu guy a lot of times
you wrestler might beat you up on the
ground you might ground and pound you
but yeah jiu-jitsu guys probably just
gonna choke you but Vic kickboxers gonna
slam its [ __ ] shin in your face do you
not want that man you do not want that
oh it's the worst way to lose the worst
way to lose it to a striker weekend no
this is a fastest-ever knockout in UFC
history this guy Jorge Masvidal knocked
out this two-time Olympic wrestler Ben
Askren he was a beast of a wrestler and
it knocked about five seconds
cuz Askren went to shoot to try to get a
hold of his legs and monster doll ran
out I'm with a flying knee and hit him
right in the face while he's trying to
bend forward that's legal yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah it's legal that's it right there oh
oh [ __ ] it's all over the Internet you
want to see it
so yeah takes five seconds it was one of
those things where we watched it we went
holy [ __ ] like as it happened okay is
that us talking about it yeah but that
one don't mind uh you just turned away
from I wasn't the one below it that
wasn't it you're hosing it no it wasn't
it oh it's other people talking about
the reaction I see it's definitely on
Instagram but apparently it's getting
pulled left and right yeah of course
they're gonna try to do that which it's
just it's just like that's for everybody
let everybody have that like no we need
that we need to own that commodity but
that's it's it's good for everybody
it's not how the internet works either
you don't win here hands here we go so
this is the beginning in the fight ready
this is round one yep
how cold
five second call by the RAF though yeah
it wasn't even really five seconds he
was out cold at three seconds they
summoned a time from here boom
how cold three seconds and as the
referees running over to him yeah I'm
why is he yelling at him we hated each
other really I they hate each other
Jorge Masvidal said that guy was
taunting him for like ten years talking
[ __ ] to him so he couldn't wait to do
that to him
yeah now what well Ben dusts himself off
he took it like a man I mean he really
did he went on
talk show and talked about it afterwards
and good yeah that's that's how you
[ __ ] to shake yeah yeah I said clock
it sucks I don't like losing that guy's
a douche Yeah right
but they're probably gonna end up being
somewhat friend friendly later down the
line no you don't think so no Moz Vidal
said that if you saw him at the Whole
Foods it's not over he's still smack her
in the face
even Whole Foods couldn't hold him but
Whole Foods can't hold back right for
the kombucha the real GTS kombucha the
kind of needed a credit you getting to
shave Aidid again
[Applause]